of course the second i hit record that
dog starts barking
yeah fix the damn dog
[Music]
been a while since we talked about some
spider-man jazz
okay let's get this one out of the way
signed everyone from cast and crew
spider-man no way home and there's this
one signature there where everyone's
like is this toby mcguire's signature
i'm pretty sure this is tyler mcguire's
signature at this point
with everything that's been coming out i
mean you believe he's in it right
absolutely i
believe he's like the worst kept secret
in hollywood right now
it seems pretty likely this report came
out a couple days ago but it seems to
have caught a lot of traction
today and it's something that i am very
much
invested in so i wanted to talk about it
i believe you are too
considering how safe to say both of our
favorite spider-man is toby mcguire
yeah no offense to the others we love
the others stubby mcguire is our
personal favorite
so the main rumor is that spider-man 4
might actually be happening
with toby maguire starring in it sam
raimi directing and that this would take
place
after doctor strange multiverse of
madness so
it would be semi-connected just due to
events because of that
right that's like the main rumor
circulating i have my reasons for why i
want this spider-man 4 to happen
but i also have reasons why
realistically what
probably will not happen although i'm
hoping i'm wrong about those reasons
all the same but before diving into any
of that i think it's important to do
just a
quick quick recap of what went wrong
with spider-man 3
and what was supposed to happen with
spider-man 4 and to see how any of that
might actually affect
the development of toby maguire sam
raimi getting a chance to reunite for
spider-man 4. all right so for
spider-man 3 we all pretty much know
what happened
he didn't want venom he didn't want to
get hit with that venom he didn't know
what hit him
he didn't want venom in there as i uh
wear this shirt
in case sam raimi's watching this so he
feels provoked by venom being in this
video
he only wanted sandman in there and he
wanted harry osborn to have his arc
conclude and he didn't quite get venom
and
avi arid who is all about that venom
it's like hey man you don't get fans you
need to put venom in here clearly what
you're doing is not working sam raymond
put venom in here punch this thing up
and make it more edgy
that's just the most bizarre part to me
is like where was this statement coming
from
of you're not listening to the fans
enough did you not see the reception
spider-man 2 and that wasn't as much of
a thing back then there wasn't the same
twitter verse we have now where people
can just go and directly complain to a
filmmaker
and people were also pretty happy with
the changes that
sam raimi was making you know letting
sam raimi do his thing worked for the
franchise and then obviously with the
studio meddling he ended up producing
directing a movie
he himself does not like he's not a fan
of the film spider-man 4
was announced and this movie had one
main goal
redemption redemption for everything
that went wrong for spider-man 3.
sam raimi had a goal in mind of i gotta
just make it what i want it to be
and it has to be the best spider-man
movie he will not settle for anything
less than great like i'm paraphrasing it
but that's pretty much exactly what he
was saying
is that this has to be a great movie and
he had some wild plans for it first off
he wanted to make sure
he wasn't going to let any bit of sony
influence his decision-making on who the
villain should be so he had this idea
for the main villain to be vulture
played by john malkovich then he wanted
to have felicia hardy being here played
by anne hathaway and felicia hardy more
known as black cat he was actually going
to do his own thing and have her arc
into
vultrus i don't know if you know about
any of this but in the beginning of the
movie
he wanted to do this like montage of
spider-man apprehending all these
villains
that he never saw as becoming a main
villain in the movies he was doing
people like the shocker people like the
prowler people like
not paul giamatti rhino but the the
onesie rhino he wanted to do
and then he had a fun bit in mind for
mysterio and he wanted bruce campbell to
play him so he'd be like this
overweight mysterio you'd have kind of
this fun montage at the beginning which
i imagine nowadays if that's what he did
i think that would just piss off a lot
of fans
yeah like what the hell you're wasting
all these villains like that's how
i think nowadays it would have been
right i think at the time though i think
we would have had a lot of fun watching
that
yeah i mean in a time where you don't
have so much pressure to hold on to
people just in case we need to make them
super important later and i mean over
the years he's expressed interest with
that spider-man 4 project of even
bringing in lesser-known
villains to the fold and stuff like that
there was a point where they were like
let's make morbius the living vampire
one of the main villains in here
nowadays who wouldn't work to do like a
medley or cram a bunch in but at the
time we were talking about before
superhero movies were the
big franchise monoliths they are now i
think that could have been
an interesting way to go about it i mean
at the end of the day
his main focus was on telling the story
of peter parker focus being peter parker
mary jane
and harry osborne like the three main
characters
specifically peter right so i think even
in doing that with some of your villains
at the beginning
i don't think he would have lost sight
of wanting to conclude the peter parker
journey because that's how this was
supposed to be this should serve as
the closing book on his franchise and if
they wanted to negotiate for part five
or a part six then they could talk about
it but this
would have been like in case i wanted to
end it this would be the end
right so they had the writer james
vanderbilt on board but in the middle of
production the script wasn't going the
way he wanted it to go
he became very much aware that sony was
already like
hey maybe we should just reboot this
eventually he gave up
then we got amazing spider-man that
franchise failed now we have tom hall in
the mcu
and that's going where are we at right
now first off i don't think this would
be the spider-man 4 he was originally
envisioning
no yeah it's got to be you know it's
decades removed now so it's got to be
updated and a whole new idea by this
point
and i'm wondering how much if you were
to get permission to do this if they
were going to hand this over to him
like why would sony let this happen why
would they let him do this spider-man
movie i think it's because
in the amount of time we're talking
about spider-man 3 the
most hype it's been getting is the
possibility
of yes all the spider-man joining but
let's face facts toby mcguire is the one
that's getting most
i'm not talking about your personal
opinion let's look at the masses here
andrew garfield these conversations
would be a little different
but every single time it's toby mcguire
toby maguire is the one that keeps going
trending
obviously with studios being mainly
concerned about money and monetization
and all that
clearly they're like well damn it looks
like people really want to see more
tobey mcguire
already yeah i don't even think toby
mcguire cares to see more toby but
tom mcguire strikes me as the kind of
guy with and you give him the right
paycheck he'll do the right job you know
yeah that seems fair especially with
what we heard about the negotiations
surrounding this movie
yeah i think this would be really cool
for him to do mainly because
i think it's really shitty what's
happening with him i think it's
especially crappy in the sense of he
makes
two very iconic spider-man movies and
then for
years and years and years and years
everyone just gives him crap about
spider-man 3. yeah which
is largely dogged by decisions he didn't
want to make
yeah yeah and so it makes an interesting
case because it does
approach a precedent because you had the
snyder cut and then you have this idea
and it seems like
you know hollywood's a big machine that
oftentimes makes decisions that go
against filmmakers wishes go against
what they
really wanted in their heart and soul
for a film or whatever so i'm like
at this point the more we do this the
more of just a thing it's gonna become
i'm curious to see what hollywood does
because like a new genre can't just
become
the redemption film can it well you know
you said snyder cut and and to me
that's exactly why i think this would
not happen that's the main reason why
because i think sam raimi would want
more control of what he would do with
like if i'm gonna do this
i have to be able to do it my way and
there is
literally nothing about sony that has
demonstrated there's a possib this was
like
plum house maybe but but there's nothing
about
sony specifically that has demonstrated
that they would let him
be like yeah i want to do my own thing
like i think it would be cool if we did
kind of get a snyder cut version
like i know there's not a version of
this film that already exists but if he
was like yeah i'm just going to do what
i wanted to originally do
i'm going to have my weird opening
montage maybe evil dead to
that where it's like partially a remake
of spider-man 3 but it's partially it's
kind of own movie
yeah and i think actually in a weird way
by keeping that original intro that he
had in mind
because you know scripts that was still
the early development stages of the
script that's just what they had in mind
at the beginning you know
let's say we went into a time machine
and they finally got around to filming
it
maybe that opening montage wouldn't even
be there by the time
they got around to being on set right
point being you know even if you do have
that opening montage
it would be a good way to establish that
oh this is definitely not
taking over the mcu spider-man this is
like you
an overweight bruce campbell mysterio
right here this is not the same thing
yeah this is his own thing and i feel
like out of any franchise
currently more than the flash more than
doctor strange multiverse of madness
more than
any franchise spider-man's the one
where you i think it's already done
right they already have it established
like they have into the spider-verse
they have the spider-man with the tom
hollands and they
got the venom movie i mean they already
have their multiverse they beat
everybody to the multiverse i feel like
spider versus the door kicking open you
know that's my point
is the spider verse movie is already set
the precedent for
yeah there could be any numbers you
could do a spider-man 4 and i feel like
people would be on board and it wouldn't
confuse audiences
yeah again the spider-verse was such a
huge hit that i feel like even the lay
person who's aware of that movie might
go oh maybe this is one of those
alternate universe ones you know
yeah and i think that there's so much
trauma
and so much burnout that came out with
sam raimi and i'm sure there's been
stuff that just tubby mcguire hasn't
been vocal about
of his heck his video was high beyond
his back pain
i'm sure there's experience he's had
that he hasn't been vocal about and same
thing with sam raimi you know like i
think that
in order for them to do this they would
need to have as much control as possible
over the creative decision-making and i
just don't see a scenario where sony
would let that happen and that's the
only reason why i don't think
they would proceed with signing
contracts to do this movie yeah yeah
that's a pretty selling point i love it
i'd like to see it i'd like to see
whatever weird ideas they'd have
the reason i wanted to bring out what
went wrong with spider-man 3 and the
cancelled spider-man 4
is because how much has really changed
not a lot honestly and else this sounds
like what we've seen with wb even
recently
yeah this is studio filmmaking right
here and these are the trials and
tribulations
all right guys well spider-man 4 would
you want it to happen do you think it
would be too confusing leave your
thoughts down below you can subscribe to
the real rejects click that notification
bell
hit that like button last but not least
pandemic jones paul pj
just want to shout you out send you some
love and uh lets you know
that i swear to god i'm gonna get to
that new olivia rodrigo music video i
know she's your favorite artist
on the planet earth my friend we will
get
there but uh i just want to shout you
out today partly because you know
me gotta link everyone to the topic of
the video and if anyone at patreon could
be
then perfect next peter parker type i
think it's you
i look at your profile pic and i'm like
look at this guy he looks sweet maybe
he's a little unassuming maybe he's
ready to let
his hero side out after getting into
some kind of radioactive spider incident
or whatever you know you could
it could be like a big rat or something
or whatever you want pick your power
but uh save some lives out there
everybody spiderman or a big rat
according to your profile pic
not i that was just off the top i mean
you could be a male model based off your
profile all
this is the most uh continuity any shout
out
love you buddy